as you know supreme court justice ruth
bader ginsburg died last friday she
passed away of cancer
it was a sad moment because death is
always sad no matter who dies
death is coming for all of us someday
for that reason we ought to mark a
person's passing with the bow of respect
take a moment for humility and
perspective meditate on the fragility of
our own lives and the lives of those we
love
remember that death is the one thing
that unites every human being
no matter how powerful we imagine we are
at some point we will be gone
all of us in our case we almost never
agreed with justice ginsburg's decisions
but on friday night's show we did our
best to show some reverence
because that's the right thing to do the
left by contrast made no attempt at all
prominent progressives immediately
descended into hysteria and
rage unbridled rage they told us that
ruth bader ginsburg's death
was more than sad they said it was a
national crisis that imperiled this
country's freedoms
ruth bader ginsburg they told us
single-handedly kept america from
descending into fascism and
tyranny now that she's gone only her
words can keep us safe
that's an odd claim if you think about
it this is supposed to be a democracy
no one ever voted for ruth bader
ginsburg no matter how much you
liked her or agreed with her she was in
the end a single judge
in a country of 350 million people she
was not god
yet according to the left ginsburg was
all we had
we must obey her dying words as if they
were a religious text
her final wish supersedes our founding
documents
what would ruth bader ginsburg do we
must ask ourselves that
and then do it watch as a nation
we should heed her final call to us
not as a personal service to her but as
a service
to the country our country at a
crossroads
honor her last words that she not be
replaced
until a new president is installed she
said
my most fervent wish is that i will not
be replaced
by an until a new president is installed
we believe that her fervent wish
is that the next president picked that
was the last thing
she said to the public we know who this
man is
we know who this man is this is a man
who does not care about a dying woman's
final wish
clearly so
turn down the volume and consider for a
moment the reasoning here the argument
that they're making
nothing is more important than our
constitution that constitution is in
grave jeopardy
that's why we must substitute an 87 year
old woman's final wish
for the constitutionally prescribed
process
for filling a supreme court seat that's
what they're arguing got that
pretty amusing keep in mind we don't
really know actually what ruth bader
ginsburg's final words were did she
really leave this world fretting about a
presidential election
we don't believe that for a second if it
were true
it would be pathetic because life is
bigger than politics even this year
we wouldn't wish final words that small
on anyone so we're going to again
choose to believe that ruth bader
ginsburg didn't really say that that in
real life
she was thinking at the end about her
family and where she might be going next
human concerns not partisan ones
but in practical terms it's irrelevant
what she said ruth bader ginsburg
doesn't get to pick her replacement from
her deathbed that's not how it works we
have a constitution we're supposed to be
defending remember and that's the whole
point
of the constitution if justice scalia
had said something like that
nobody would have cared we would have
been embarrassed for him
thankfully he didn't say that on some
level democrats know all this
all this talk about ginsburg's dying
wish is ridiculous
and insulting to all of us and our
country and they'll stop soon
democrats have an alternative argument
at the ready and that's one they've been
honing all year it goes like this
do what we want or we will hurt you
that's the real argument they're making
reza ocelon a longtime cnn employee
wrote this in the hours after ginsberg
died quote
if they even try to replace rbg we burn
the entire effing thing down
that effing thing being our country that
we built
on friday night another democrat tweeted
instructions for how to begin that
process quote
we're now walking to mitch mcconnell's
house to protest
more than a hundred and twenty thousand
people like that post
shockingly the follow-up came a few
minutes later quote his house is
entirely dark significant police
presence out front it's not clear
that he's here it's clear that he's not
here as confirmed by a neighbor who is
not fond of him people are going home
that's not a protest that's a threat
the point of it was to terrorize mitch
mcconnell and his family mcconnell knew
it was coming because that's how things
seem to work now the police guarding his
house are probably the only reason it's
still standing
watch
[Music]
[Applause]
we shouldn't be surprised by that it was
just last year that another group of
democrats gathered outside mitch
mcconnell's home chanting death threats
it was all on video
we put up with it of course so it's
happened again you get what you put up
with
that's true of children it's true of
countries and we're putting up with this
so we shouldn't be surprised
who's doing it well trump voters are
fascists they tell us
but when was the last time trump voters
threatened democratic politicians in
their home it's hard to
recall that happening no the tactics are
always the same
and it's always the same people doing it
then in case mitch mcconnell didn't get
the message
biden voters assembled at the home of
senator lindsey graham graham chairs the
senate judiciary committee
they wanted to honor ruth bader
ginsburg's dying wish by making sure
that graham was intimidated watch
[Music]
[Music]
these aren't spontaneous demonstrations
no of course not they're organized on
social media and they're happening for a
reason
the democratic party has encouraged this
extremism
over and over and over again nightly we
tell you about it
but it never ends it gets worse last
night the senate majority leader chuck
schumer of new york held a press
conference targeting mitch mcconnell by
name
hard to imagine that but it happened and
schumer invited sandy cortez a
first-term congresswoman from the bronx
here's what they said if you want to get
back at mitch mcconnell's blatant
nasty
hypocrisy call your senator and tell
them
not to listen to mitch mcconnell not to
be afraid of mitch mcconnell
and to mitch mcconnell we need to tell
him that he is playing with fire
we need to tell him that he is playing
with fire
really that's a threat and on instagram
sandy cortez america's most pampered
revolutionary went ahead
and suggested that democrats go further
maybe even embrace violence
watch let this moment
radicalize you will you focus on voting
for joe biden i don't care if you like
him or not
this is not over you know we win in
november
i'm sorry to tell you you're not going
back to brunch we're not going back to
branch
that's not happening we're not going
back to brunch
so now you know what a freshman member
of congress
was doing standing at the podium with
the most powerful democrat
in the senate why would he choose sandy
cortez
well because sandy cortez doesn't simply
represent a congressional district she
doesn't do that very well
no her real role is as commander of the
youth wing of the democratic party the
direct
action wing the thugs who have spent the
last three and a half months burning and
destroying in some cases killing
on behalf effectively of the joe biden
for president campaign
cortez and her followers use these
tactics for one simple reason you know
why
because they work this summer a bar
owner in omaha called jake gardner was
attacked during a blm riot there a man
called james spurlock jumped on
gardner's back and put him in a
chokehold gardner shot spurlock in order
to save his own life
it was clearly self-defense and that's
what prosecutors concluded
but then biden voters took direct action
they took to the streets what does that
mean exactly well in this case
it means they gathered outside the home
of douglas county attorney don klein
and they threatened him their presence
was a threat and guess what
it worked last week gardner was charged
with manslaughter
this weekend gardner killed himself
see how that works do you want to live
in a country like that
megan hunt does megan hunt is a state
senator from omaha she is glad
jake gardner is dead megan hunt
congratulated the mob on twitter for
pushing
jake gardner to suicide hunt encouraged
them to do it to others
as hunt wrote on twitter and we're
quoting jake gardner is gone but the
white supremacist attitudes that
emboldened him
are still with us today end quote in
other words
you know what to do this should terrify
you
democratic leaders have decided that
everything is allowed in pursuit of
power
nothing is off limits give us what we
want or we will hurt you
in terms nancy pelosi can understand
that means maybe another impeachment
some have mentioned the possibility if
they try to push through a nominee in a
lame duck session
that that you in the house could move to
impeach
president president trump or attorney
general barr as a way of stalling and
preventing the senate from acting
on this nomination well we have our
options we have arrows
in our quiver that i'm not about to
discuss right now
oh impeach the president for what for
following
the constitution's letter
for doing what the constitution tells
presidents to do when there's a supreme
court vacancy
could that really happen what would the
trial look like we accuse you of
following the law
probably not going to happen plus he
knows that that's why she's got
other arrows in the quiver as she said
one of those arrows is direct force
on saturday california governor gavin
newsom's chief of staff tweeted this
quote i am ready to fly to d.c in the
middle of covet 19
and lay my body on the floor of the
united states senate to prevent a vote
from occurring before the next term of
congress
end quote if she did that many would
join her and maybe they'll do it
maybe they'll come to washington and
physically prevent lawmakers
from voting that's never happened before
in the history of our country it could
happen now
people are calling for it does that seem
like extremism to you
yeah but if it does keep in mind you're
the extremist
you're the one who's willing to do
anything for power including use force
here's hillary clinton neatly explaining
that her sins
are in fact your sins what's happening
in our country is incredibly uh
dangerous our institutions are being
basically undermined by the lust
for power power for personal gain in the
case of the
president or power for institutional uh
gain in the case of mitch mcconnell
okay so if you're following at home just
want to be clear on how this works
democrats are so worried about your
attempts to
undermine our institutions that they in
the end may have to burn those
institutions down
sorry your extremism did it